tonight we will be talking about a film
called youth and I thought we'd start
out by talking about your youth because
it definitely was not inevitable that a
kid from Elephant & Castle this poor
neighborhood London yeah was gonna
become Michael Caine in fact he wasn't
even named Michael Caine at that point
no I wasn't no no the way I got my name
was I was I was a repertory actor in in
in the country you know and I didn't
belong to equity the trade union and I
came to London and I had an agent and I
didn't have a telephone and so I used to
end in Leicester Square there was a
telephone which is like Times Square
here you know
and every every evening on weekdays
hosts have phoned my agent saying have
you got a job for me and one night I
thought she said I've got a job she said
but you you I called my real name is
Mickel white and I called myself Michael
white you know so that's fine and she
said I've got a job so but you've got to
belong to equity and you can't be called
Michael white because there's always it
is already an actor called Michael white
in equity she said you know you can call
yourself Michael
but you can't call yourself white and I
need a name now think of a name and I
was in Leicester Square which is like
Broadway with all cinemas and my
favorite actor is Humphrey Bogart at
that time and I look round and it said
Humphrey Bogart in the Caine Mutiny so I
said that's a good name
so I said she said I said you know call
me Cain Michael Caine she said how you
spell it I said CAI any but hey it was a
good job it wasn't the next year there
because I'd have been called Michael 101
dalmatians I tell us a little bit about
your character Fred fred is a composer
and conductor who's as he said there
he's done these songs and but the
mystery of the whole film is the wife so
I can't explain that you know but he's
on holiday it's
whistlin with his best friend who's a
movie producer who'd played by Harvey
Keitel and and and it's it's a sort of
fantasy the world that he lives in and
you said you've seen that that's very
sort of seriously quite miserable you
know but a film is better right as low
to music is very funny beautiful
location and its locations and it is
it's Paulo you know Santi no dude it's
just so clever with what he does you
know and and but for me it was a
wonderful part and what I didn't
understand was his Paulo said he'd
written it for me
and I thought he's written him for me
and he's such a great director because
I'd seen all his other stuff I didn't
even know he if he knew who I was let
alone your own picture so I did it and
and I had the best time from but from an
artistic point of view of working I
really I'm really very very proud of
this this movie it's it's a it's among
the best work that I ever did there's
lots of talk in the film about seeing
the future and looking back at the past
and how we're all sort of caught between
the two there's a there's a lovely
moment or Harvey Keitel flips around a
telescope it's a wonderful moment it's
yeah yeah I'll be talking to a young man
he said you see look at that he said and
he looked through the hotel food
telescope he said that's the future and
he can see all these big things he turns
a telescope round he looks and
everything is gone he said that's the
past
I thought it was a great simile for
future and past and it's very difficult
to explain this movie because it's on
such a high intellectual plane and so
clever because he is clever you know I
mean Paulo he writes it as well
and I was some time possibly emotion I
mean there were tears in our screening
room the other day it's yeah yeah yeah
well I mean it it we showed it in can
and it we got seven and a half the
seventeen and a half minute standing
ovation which by the way is very
difficult but you don't know what to do
you're standing there you go to go and
you think oh you saw Albin go and
they'll stop they didn't stop though you
guys so you've got to sit down as he
can't sit down there clubbing and so
you're standing there and we stood there
for seventeen and a half minutes and I
became fascinated by about 20 people who
were booing I thought well we're not a
complete succession there's that list of
film credits that come before the ones
that we all know and that we're famous
and their credits like I have oh yeah
there's 20 27 movies I think I did where
I played the butler you know came in and
said you know it was a it was obviously
you know a test for Batman but all I
ever said with dinner is served you know
would you like a beverage with that or I
be the policeman who came in and
arrested the villain at the end and then
and then it all starts to happen right
Zulu if Kris files Shirley MacLaine sees
you in it Kris yeah she brought me to
Hollywood and I came to Hollywood and I
was there two weeks before she got there
because she was making another movie and
so I didn't get my sort of party to
introduce me to everyone so I stayed in
the Beverly Hills Hotel in a great big
luxury suite all on my own
and no one ever talked to me or anything
and no one called me nothing happened so
I used to go down into the lobby and see
if I could see any film stars and I sat
in the lobby and John Wayne came in John
Wiley and he had to hurry he got off a
helicopter straight out of the desert he
was covered in dust and everything he
was checking in at the Beverly Hills
Hotel and he looked over he saw me -
what's your name kid I said Michael
Kaiser you're in that movie called Alfie
I said yeah he said you're gonna be a
big star kid I took think of mr. Wayne
and he said let me give you some advice
he said jog low don't talk slow and
don't say too much
never wear suede shoes
I said what why never wear suede she
says it because as I said it's here but
you're gonna be very famous he said and
you're begun in the toilet and taking a
pee there'll be a guy next to you and
he's gonna say Michael Caine and he's
gonna pee all over your shoes let's talk
about the accent you know the Internet
is filled with tributes to the Michael
Caine voice I just showed you this oh
yeah ma yeah are you and you don't you
go I don't totally different anyone else
do I and my wife or is it no no Michael
you don't it's alright it's okay but
somehow or other I've got a different
accent but what I did is the voice I've
got was a voice that I I did for America
because when Alfie came out I mean Elfi
came out in England was a big success
fine and I was on making something else
anyway it does matter I was making
something else and the director rang he
said we want you to do a hundred and
twenty loops for Alfie I said before he
said the Americans have bought it and
they don't know what you're talking
about so if you see the American version
of Alfie looks like I don't know how to
do it cockney accent when you talk about
the kind of acting you wanted to do and
working against the mainstream you know
being a working-class guy trying to make
it it almost feels to me like Laurence
olivia is the definition of kind of
cinema you were pushing back against an
you to clash in that film I'll tell you
a story about Larry I was out about two
weeks before I made Laurence Olivier was
Lord Olivier right so we're gonna make
this film to go there's only two of us
in it sleuth him and me we'd never met
and about two weeks before the picture I
got a letter from him saying it has
occurred to me that you may be wondering
how to address me
how to address me when we meet they said
let me say this from the moment we say
hello I am Larry which I thought was
great and it got me off the hook on that
but I remade I remade a sleuth with Jude
Law many years later and I said listen
and I was Sir Michael Caine and he
wasn't and I said if it was a boating I
said Jude a letter saying you may be
wondering how to address me I would hate
with a question would it say does ever
get competitive no I have no sense of
competition with other actors I my
competition is with myself I'm all I'm
ever doing is trying to be better than I
was the last time I mean I admire other
actually as I work with great actors and
I really love working with it's a very
funny thing
I can't work with bad actors and it
really because I keep I'm looking at
them and I always forget my lines I got
you should have said that you've done
that that way and I suddenly become
interested in how bad they are and I
forgot what I'm supposed to say so no
but you know you must work with good
people otherwise you'll be crap
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]